Let's compare kinetic
energies in a two particle
one-dimensional collision in
different reference frames.
So we could have
one reference frame
in which particle 1 is
coming in and particle 2 is
moving like that.
And in particular-- so we can
call this the ground frame.
And now let's consider
the center of mass frame.
And in the center
of mass frame, let's
remind you that when we have
two different reference frames,
the velocity-- we'll call
this the ground frame
g-- in the ground frame is equal
to the velocity of the object--
we'll actually write it
this way, just unprime,
V1-- the velocity in the
center of mass frame--
so this is the velocity
in the cm frame--
plus the relative velocities
between the frames.
And that's why that's the
velocity of the center of mass.
So this was our
rule for describing
how velocities change in
different reference frames.
And so we can draw the
picture in the center
of mass frame, V1 initial
prime and V2 initial prime.
Now let's compare
kinetic energies
in these different frames.
So we know that
the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame is
just 1/2 m1 V1 initial squared
prime-- put the prime
there-- plus 1/2
V2 initial prime
squared, kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame.
How do we calculate the kinetic
energy in the lab frame?
Well, that's a little
bit more complicated.
And we'll need a little
algebra to start that.
So let's put kinetic
energy in the ground frame.
We know is 1/2 m1
V1 initial squared
plus 1/2 m2 V2 initial squared.
Now what I have to do is use the
law, the velocity relationship.
And this is going to take
a little bit algebra.
We have m1-- I'll write
V1 prime plus Vcm.
And remember that any quantity
squared is the dot product,
V dot V. So I'm going
to dot this with itself.
V1 initial prime plus
the center of mass.
And I have the second
term which looks
identical to this first term.
I'll write it all
the way down here.
1/2 m2 V2 initial
prime plus Vcm.
Vector dot scalar dot product
of V2 initial prime plus Vcm.
Now when you take a
dot product, remember
there's four terms here.
There's V1 prime dot V1 prime,
which is just V1 prime squared.
There's V center of mass
dot V center of mass.
So that's V center
of mass squared.
And then there's the cross term.
And because they're identical,
there's a factor of 2.
And it will be repeated below.
So the kinetic energy in
the ground frame is 1/2 m1.
So we'll take v1 i prime
dotted with itself.
That's V1 i prime squared.
We have the cross
term, which is a factor
of 2, which will cancel this.
So the cross term is . m1.
That canceled the factor of 2.
V1 i prime dot Vcm plus
the Vcm with itself.
So that's 1/2 m1 Vcm squared.
Now I have exactly the
same thing on the next one.
So we'll write that down.
1/2 V2 i prime squared
plus m2 V2i prime dot Vcm.
That's the same in both.
Plus 1/2 m2 Vcm squared.
Now let's look
carefully at what we.
Have 1/2 m1 V1 prime squared.
This is an m2.
1/2 m2 V2 i prime squared.
So we have 1/2 m1
V1i prime squared
plus 1/2 m2 V2i prime squared.
And you're already noticing
that's the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame.
We have the total mass,
1/2 m1 plus m2 Vcm squared.
I can just put a
little check to show
which terms I've done so far.
And now here's the
interesting one.
We have m1 V1i prime plus
m2 V2i prime dot Vcm.
That represents this term
and this term added together.
But recall that the center
of mass reference frame
is defined by the condition
that the total momentum
in that frame is zero.
So this term is zero.
And thus, we get that the
kinetic energy in the ground
frame is equal to
the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame
plus 1/2 m1 plus m2 times Vcm
squared.
And that's how kinetic energy is
in different reference frames.
And the next thing
we'll look at is
how that changes when
we have a collision.